I wanted to Google image it and get a visual,
but I don't remember the name of the show
because all I heard was bidi bidi bong bong.
And I'm like, "I don't know what words you
actually said."
Yeah, bidi bidi bong bong.
So Nina, what is the forgotten kids show that
you think deserves its own cinematic universe?
Thanks for asking Brian.
So, I'm a child of the '90s.
I watched a lot of Rugrats and early Nickelodeon
programming.
There was one show that I really loved when
I was a kid and it kind of became a cinematic
universe or at least movie, but by a different
name.
And I'm here to defend it's honor.
And the show is 1994s Aaahh!!!
Real Monsters.
Which-
Ooh.
Yeah.
That's a good show.
And Aaahh!!!
Real Monsters walked so that Monsters Inc.
could run.
It's the same premise made way beforehand.
So it's three monsters who live in the sewers
and go to school to learn how to scare kids.
And they're-
Can I see if I remember their names?
You certainly can.
And I'm going to send you guys a picture and
I want you to tell me which one is which.
Oh, okay.
And I remembered which one was which, which
just goes to show.
I can't retain any new information, but I
still know this.
So, that's cool.
No I'm-
I think I know these.
I'm coming at this as somebody that, I didn't
have cable growing up.
Mm-hmm.
So this is all new to you.
Can I just kind of...?
Okay, cool.
I love that.
Tom.
Why don't you guess first?
Can I guess what their names are?
Why don't you guess their names first and
then I'll come in and rescue you?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I want to hear what you think their names
are, Tom, because this is going to be good.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, okay.
So in the middle, I'm going to say Joe Pesci
from Casino.
Then to the right, let's say his name is Larry
Gibbleman.
And then up top is Schplarnk.
Schplarnk.
How did I do?
You're not too far off with that last one.
No, you're not.
Schplarnk?
Surprised.
Surprised to say.
Your biggest stumble is that you gave them
first and last names and they only have one
name each.
This is...
That's right.
Way to go.
I think my biggest stumble is that Schplarnk
is going to turn out to be Danish for a really
provocative word.
A really bad word.
Please continue.
Sorry.
So the one in the middle is Ickis.
Yes.
Okay.
The one on the right is Krumm.
Yes.
Mm-hmm.
And the one on top is Oblina.
That's correct.
Yes.
That's beautiful.
And their teacher was The Gromble.
Yes.
Voiced by the legendary Tim Curry.
Actually, no.
Tim Curry voiced The Gromble's assistant.
I'm just looking up his name.
Zimbo.
No.
Yeah.
The Gromble was Gregg Berger with whom I am
less familiar.
He seems to be mostly a voice actor.
Okay.
We're going to...
I don't know.
I'm getting-
Gregg Berger is a great man.
I'm going to look this up right now.
I'm getting this-
From the Internet's resource, Wikipedia.
So it's got to be true.
We're going to pause-
You guys go ahead.
You guys argue.
We're going to pause the feed right here.
I'm going to do a pitch for Gregg Burgers.
We're going to pause the show.
Pause.
Okay, we're unpausing.
I mean, the internet says...
All right, well I've-
With all the Gregg a grilling boy needs, Gregg
Burgers.
I've derailed all of it, and I'm sorry.
Because I really thought Tim Curry voiced
The Gromble.
But Tim Curry was involved in the show.
Okay.
Pretty heavily actually.
This show was great.
Yeah.
I do remember that they adopted a dog once
named Pustule.
Yeah.
I forgot about Pustule.
They had a whole song.
That's a great dog name.
They had a whole song about it.
And it only ran for, I think it was like 50...
Like 52 episodes or something?
It was really short.
Yeah, 52 episodes, four seasons.
And it's by the same people who did Rugrats.
Mm-hmm.
But it never got the love that Rugrats did.
Probably because Rugrats was about cute babies,
and this was about disgusting monsters.
Ugly monsters.
But then years later, you have Krumm in the
form of Mike Wazowski.
And I'm not saying Pixar stole it, but I'm
also not, not saying that Pixar stole it.
Yeah.
There are definitely some similarities.
These monsters went to school to learn how
to scare.
Yes.
Yeah.
It's Monsters University.
It's Monsters University, right.
Is basically what it is.
But also Mike Wazowski, except that he has
one giant eye instead of holding his eyeballs,
there's some Krumm DNA to be found in there
I would argue.
The short spot monster.
Prominent armpit hair.
Yeah.
So yeah.
I would love to see this make a comeback with
an animated movie and a whole universe because
there's got to be more Real Monsters where
these three came from and I want to see what
else is out there.
And yeah, I don't think it got the love it
deserved.
Making those three into photorealistic CGI
monsters would...
I think that that's what the next generation
of kids needs.
I feel like their world isn't terrifying enough.
Yeah.
You know what?
That's a great idea.
Let's make like a Polar Express style, Uncanny
Valley.
Yeah.
Computer generated Aaahh!
Real monsters.
Tom Hanks is Schplarnk.
Ooh.
I love it.
I mean the creature designs are truly...
They are...
If you were to apply that to anything outside
of the realm of animation, they would be truly
gross and disgusting.
They would be horrifying.
Yeah.
But drawn they're funny.
I think that's to their benefit.
Yes.
Krumm is funny.
He sleeps with his eyeballs in a water glass
and he loses them all the time.
He's constantly losing his eyes.
It's a great gag.
Yeah.
They're all really funny and their animation's
all really clever.
Oh, and it's also the dude from Pan's Labyrinth.
Right?
Oh my...
Yeah, with the...
A little bit.
Because he's got the eyes in his hands?
Same deal.
Basically Aaahh!!!
Real Monsters is the genesis for so much great
art and it deserves its day.
I mean, if you think about it...
If you think about a Real Monsters cinematic
universe, or at least a live action movie
and use mostly practical effects, how cool
would that be?
Yeah.
That would be awesome.
I would definitely go see that.
And it would be such a nostalgia thing for
kids who...
I think it was probably paired with Rugrats.
I mean, it must've been in the same block
because I was sitting there watching it.
Yeah.
And so, everyone who was four, five, six at
that time remembers that show.
Yeah.
It was ahead of its time.
I was in middle school.
Yeah.
Well...
So I watched it anyway because I had nothing
else going on.
That's okay.
I watched a lot of Degrassi The Next Generation
in high school instead of having friends.
There you go.
Yeah.
It all tracks.
Anyway, that's my pick, is Aaahh!!!
Real Monsters.
That's a good pick.
Thank you.
I had two that I thought of and one I've settled
on.
I'm so excited.
The first one that I wanted to talk about,
but I've decided I'll just mention it, was
a show called Centurions.
Do either of you know Centurions?
Mm-mm.
I don't know that one.
Centurions is a show...
Both of my picks are from the '80s because
I am a child of the '80s.
And Centurions-
Don't call yourself a child.
I'm still a child.
Centurions was basically these three military
dudes on a special super team.
And they wore these body suits with holes
in them that you could plug different weapons
into.
They were awesome toys.
Okay that's pretty cool.
Basically, there was an air guy, a land guy
and a sea guy.
And they got their weapons beamed down to
them from a satellite in space and they would
fight bad guys, and it was cool.
That sounds awesome.
It was fun.
It was really cool.
But that's not the one I picked.
The one I picked is even more obscure and
it's called Bionic Six.
Do either of you know Bionic Six?
No.
All right.
It's from 1986.
It was, I believe, originally conceived of
as an animated sequel spinoff to The Six Million
Dollar Man and The Bionic Woman.
Okay.
Huh.
But they scrapped that connection, but still
made it so that...
So basically, the premise is that there's
a super secret bionic guy named Bionic-1 and
he goes on adventures.
He also happens to be a family man who has
a wife and two children and two adopted children.
And they're all on a ski trip one day, and
there's a horrible accident.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
They're exposed to alien-
But the whole family's exposed?
To radiation from an alien spaceship.
And-
That's funny.
That's different.
I thought you meant like a skiing accident.
Me too.
Like somehow they all crashed into each other
or like of-
I mean, there's an avalanche as well.
There's an avalanche as well.
Oh, okay.
It's not good for anything.
So they're all comatose.
And so Bionic-1 is like, "Hey doc, let's use
bionics."
And so they all get bionic implants and they
all get super powers.
And they're a crime fighting adventuring team
known as the Bionic Six.
Sure.
There's dad, who's Bionic-1.
He's got super strength and laser beams.
They just have numbers?
They're all one.
They're all Bionic one or whatever.
So the mom's Mother-1.
She has psychic abilities.
They're all super strong.
There's Sport-1, he's one of the kids.
He uses a baseball bat and hits things.
I love that they-
There's Rock-1...
Yeah.
So they started with the name Bionic-1.
And then they're like, "What's the most simple
way to keep this theme going?"
Yeah.
"Let's keep the number one."
And then try-
It's better than bionic one through six.
That's what I thought you-
If you think about packaging a toy...
That's what I thought you were going to say.
That would make more logical sense if you
were running...
If you were running a team of bionic super
soldiers.
But they're a family and you don't want any
one of the kids to be like, "Oh, he's four,
I'm five.
You like him better than me."
No, you each get your own code names.
Right?
Think about it.
But was one of them sport and another dork
or loser or something that made it clear that-
No.
Well kind of.
Donatello-1 does machines.
Yeah.
So there's two biological kids and there's
two adopted kids.
Yeah.
So the two biological kids are Sport-1 and
Rock-1.
Rock-1 has little speakers on her shoulders
and she blasts sonic blasts and she can run
really fast.
And she loves shopping because it was the
'80s.
Girls love shopping.
Then it gets dicey.
Now here's the part where you remember it's
the '80s.
Uh-oh.
It was a simpler time.
Cocaine-1.
It was a more reductive time.
It's not necessarily offensive, but it is
not, not offensive.
Oh boy.
So they have an Asian foster son who goes
by Karate-1.
That's not the best.
That's the big one where they're like, he's
an Asian foster son and he's good at martial
arts.
It's like, guys, it's more than that.
But he was a great character.
Oh thank god he's good at martial arts.
If he hadn't been that would've been so much
worse.
His name's Karate-1 and he sucks at karate.
Yeah.
And they have a black adopted son as well
and he goes by IQ.
He's super duper smart.
He has a robot named F.L.U.F.F.I.
And they all hang out and they all fight crime.
They're all super strong.
And it's great.
And what I'm going to do-
Not F.L.U.F.F.I.-1.
Yeah.
Why is it not F.L.U.F.F.I.-1?
It's an acronym.
It's an acronym for something, I don't know.
In the chat earlier, you were saying that
you were really excited about one of them
that you had liked when you were a kid.
Is this the one you were talking about?
This is it.
I remember watching this as a child.
I had one of the action figures for some reason.
I was four or five years old.
And it was just the coolest show.
The animation's amazing.
I mean, it sounds pretty good.
The concept is great.
It's basically Power Rangers before it's Power
Rangers.
They all have secret identities and they're
a family and they get along and they have
a good time and they go on adventures and
they beat up the bad guys.
I love it.
And if you were to make a live action version
of this or revive it today, you could easily
spin this off into so many different movies.
Because you're in a near future kind of lifestyle
going on here.
But it's also got these '80s trappings.
So it's like the future filtered through the
'80s.
So you can have a lot of fun stylistically
with that in terms of your writing and your
costumes and everything.
Think Stranger Things but in the future, I
don't know.
You want to do a retro-future show.
I don't know what I'm talking about.
Yeah.
Hold on, Brian.
It just...
Yeah?
Yes?
Did Pixar also rip off your choice?
Did they?
What about The Incredibles?
No, no.
Yeah.
For that, Pixar ripped off The Fantastic Four.
That's true.
I was just thinking superhero family, they
all have different powers.
You're not wrong.
They fight crime together.
Yeah.
It's similar in that way too.
Because the essential appeal of that show
too, it's got this retro-future style, there's
robots but it feels like it's the '60s.
Right.
It's just a good time.
It's a good concept.
And I feel like you could do Bionic Six unstuck
in time in that same way, right?
Have really futuristic stuff and really retro
stuff.
Yeah.
And it's the kind of thing too, where once
you open up the idea that like, "Oh yeah,
you could just get bionics now."
Yeah.
"I go to Albert Einstein high school."
"We have a flying minivan."
They have a flying minivan.
All of this could make for a really fun movie.
And then you open that up to what other concepts
can exist in this world.
Right.
And so, a whole cinematic universe, maybe,
maybe not.
But at the very least, a pretty good live
action franchise that I think has a lot of
potential.
To me, the Bionic Six is one of those things
that are in the back of my mind that every
time I remember it exists I get really happy.
Right.
And then I was just rewatching before our
chat.
I was like, this not only is pretty good,
but it totally holds up.
It's better than I thought that it was.
Right.
It's still kind of junky.
But it's better than you think it is, so.
So the Bionicverse.
The Bionicverse.
Yeah.
And the tragedy is that you can't easily watch
it unless you track down awful, crappy uploads
on YouTube.
Right.
So if you can find a way to watch Bionic Six,
go for it.
That's my pick.
Kid's TV from back in the day.
So, yeah.
That's me.
Awesome pick.
Bionic Six.
Thank you.
Totally.
I like it.
Everyone watch it.
Tom, what forgotten kids' show do you think
would make a great cinematic universe?
Okay.
So I had two.
They're both a '90s product.
The first one, I say semi...
I don't know how seriously to take it but...
Big Bad Beetleborgs.
Are we all familiar with the Big Bad Beetleborgs?
I'm not.
I am familiar tangentially.
They were a derivative of the Power Rangers,
basically.
Thank you very much.
Mm-hmm.
I bring a Big Bad Beetleborgs on a lot of
first dates and you would be surprised how
many people leave and pretend that they don't
know what I'm talking about.
It was a great...
So, yeah.
So the '90s brought the Power Rangers and
the whole idea of, "Let's take shows from
Japan.
Let's take the fight footage that hopefully
has a bunch of people covered head to toe
so you can't tell..."
Super Sentai shows.
Yeah.
Mm-hmm.
And then insert that into astonishingly cheaply
shot children's television shows and just
kind of write around it.
Amazing.
What I love about Big Bad Beetleborgs is that
everything about it...
It's this mish-mash of like Kirkland signature
brand versions of other stuff.
So you've got like...
Yeah, I know where you're going with this.
Yeah.
So you've got the knockoff Power Rangers,
who are three kids who get super powers and
they get to turn into beetle based Power Rangers
basically.
Oh, okay.
Yeah.
They can only do this because they get sent
into a haunted mansion.
Sure.
On a dare, and they accidentally wake up a...
He's called a phasm.
His name's Flabber.
And he's very much...
He's a cheap knockoff of the genie from Aladdin,
but by way of what do kid's love the most?
Jay Leno?
Jay Leno.
They love Jay Leno the most.
Kids love Leno.
That's what I've heard.
Kids can't get enough of him.
They love his classic cars.
Problematic late night contract deals and
yeah, no.
Yeah, yeah.
So they get superpowers from him.
The haunted house is also full of, this is
the weird one, it's full of universal movie
monsters who by their very nature are pretty...
They're already pretty generic.
Royalty free.
Yeah.
But for some reason they decided to give them
all just slight variations on the name in
case the estate of Boris Karloff came after
them.
Yeah.
It's the kind of vampire that you call a Dracula
instead of being a vampire.
It's like, "Oh, that's a Dracula."
His name is Count Fangula.
This is a The Mummy.
Is his name Fangula?
Fangula.
There's Mums the mummy.
There's a...
Is there a Frankenstein-
There's Frankenbeans the...
Okay.
I was like, what's the Frankenstein...
Well, that's at least a little clever.
Frankenbeans.
What's the Frankenstein's monster called actually.
Hilarious.
Yeah.
Yep.
Yes, no.
It's Frankenbean's monster.
And anyway, the shows...
There's a motorcycle riding grandma that absolute
shades of the Troma movie, Surf Nazis Must
Die.
It's all of the cheapest versions of other
things piled into this show.
I wanted to Google Image it and get a visual
but I don't remember the name of the show
because all I heard was bidi bidi bong bong.
And I'm like, I don't know what words you
actually said.
Yeah, bidi bidi bong bong.
It's the spinoff show that they made for Mel
Blanc's character from the old Buck Rogers.
It's called bidi bidi bong bong.
It might as well be bidi bidi bong bong.
That's what I heard.
It's Big Bad Beetleborgs.
Okay.
Sorry.
Was is Big Bad Beetleborgs?
Was that the prefix?
It was Big Bad Bettleborgs.
Until the second season when it was Beetleborgs
Metallix.
To get the new toys.
At which point they had to switch over to
a different show because they ran out of footage.
Yeah.
Right.
Oh I just found Flabber.
He's cute.
There he is.
The YouTube channel Toy Galaxy has a really
great video all about Big Bad Beetleborgs,
so if you haven't seen it I suggest...
And they have a great video about Bionic Six
as well.
So that's a really good channel that if anyone
is watching and is interested in the nonsense
we're spewing, that's a good place to go.
I'm so glad that you brought that up because
you're right.
They do great work over there.
That's the same place where I found out about
my actual pick.
Oh that wasn't your actual pick?
What?
No, no, no.
That was just my initial thought.
That was your preamble.
My actual pick was...
Damn.
There was a show, it lasted for one episode.
It was in 1992.
One.
And it was called the Defenders of Dynatron
City.
Defenders of Dynatron City, yes.
I had the comic book when I was...
You had the comic book?
This is the weirdest thing.
I was on vacation with my family in Florida.
And we were at a grocery store for some reason,
I guess getting groceries.
I was eight years old.
And my mom let me get two comic books.
One was a Married With Children comic book,
I don't know why.
And the other one was Defenders of Dynatron
City.
And I read it, and I read it, and I read it.
And I was like, "There's something...
What is this?
Why is this a thing?"
This feels like there's something large going
on here.
But there wasn't, there never was.
Tom, explain what Defenders of Dynatron City
was.
I just looked this up and wow.
Yeah, wow.
That's about it.
It's amazing.
Yeah.
Wow.
So it was created by this guy named Gary Winnick
who worked for Lucasfilm Games, it was the
studio that turned into Lucasarts eventually.
He designed this game.
There was a show that was made out of it,
it only lasted one episode.
Basically, it's this very tongue in cheek
nuclear society where everything runs on nuclear
energy and-
Retro-futurism as well.
I kind of think Fallout owes a lot to this.
Because there's a ton of themes that bled
into that.
But yeah, this very post-war Americana.
Everything's great now that everything's glowing,
kind of approach to this.
There's an evil villain whose name is Dr.
Mayhem, who has created a soda pop that's
radioactive enough to make everybody mutate
when drink it.
Wow.
And the plan was to scare everybody out of
the city with it.
But it turned out that it was delicious so
everyone just kind of went with it.
And people loved mutating.
Yeah.
Mm-hmm.
So there's just people walking around...
Like there's a kid with two heads and his
mom has an eyeball for a head and his dad
grows extra arms.
The evil villain who by the way, was originally
voiced by Christopher Walken.
And then the studio replaced him last minute
according to the creators, they wouldn't say
why.
I'm assuming because putting Christopher Walken
into any children's media turns it into an
instant nightmare.
Yeah, that would be my guess as well.
As proven by Mousehunt.
Dr. Mayhem, he winds up taking a group of...
It's going to sound like I'm making this up.
Totally does.
There's a delivery driver, an electric company
employee, there's a maintenance worker, a
dog, and a toolbox.
And he takes them all hostage.
Why does he take a toolbox hostage?
Unclear.
Okay.
I think they're carrying a tool box.
Oh.
They are carrying a toolbox.
He wasn't like, "I'm holding this toolbox
hostage."
Right.
He puts it into the cage with them and chains
up the toolbox.
Oh.
It's a terrific show.
They all wind up getting coated in the mutation
soda and electrocuted, and they walk away
with crazy superpowers.
One of them, Jett Headstrong is his name.
He gets the power to shoot his head off of
his body like a rocket.
Yep.
In what instance would that be useful?
There's a lady with a buzzsaw for legs.
Buzzsaw for legs.
Yep.
It's such a great show.
Nina, it's-
The toolbox becomes a hammer.
A hammer with a human's body and a cape.
Yeah.
Becomes a sentient...
Yeah, it has a hammer for a head.
And yeah, his hands switch out into different
tools.
What?
What does the dog do?
I got to know what the dog does.
I think it's just a super dog.
Sort of basic Krypto The Super Dog stuff.
Yeah.
It's not a...
I was expecting its tail is a propeller and...
I don't know.
I thought it was going to be much weirder.
I can see why you would.
Yeah.
I mean, it only lasted for one episode.
So assume they would have dealt with that
in episode two.
Got it.
Had it not been canceled.
Makes perfect sense to me.
Was it canceled halfway through the airing?
Probably.
10 minutes in the networks like, "Nah."
Yeah.
Fox was kind of right on the edge of starting
to do stuff like Power Rangers.
They were about to take all the cheapest shortcuts
that they could to make an original animated
program.
Probably just wasn't up their alley.
Yeah.
But it did have this crazy voice cast.
Whoopi Goldberg played one of the main characters.
What?
Ms. Megawatt.
I can't remember her name.
There was...
Tim Curry played one of the bad guys in the
first episode.
He's back.
Tim Curry again.
Wow.
Mm-hmm.
He's a legend.
He's perfect.
There was a character named Monkey Kid who
was played by Brian Stokes Mitchell.
AKA the teacher from Ghost Dad.
So there was a lot of good stuff going on
here.
Ghost Dad.
Let's not talk about Ghost Dad.
It's bananas.
We don't talk about Ghost Dad in this house.
I know we've been looking for a name for the
show for awhile.
Can we call it, "Let's not talk about Ghost
Dad"?
Yeah.
Perfect.
So that's your pick.
What would a cinematic universe of Defenders
of Dynatron City look like to you?
I think there's a ton of stuff you could do
with it.
I think that if you approached it as a tongue
in cheek, MCU situation where you're giving
all of these stupid, stupid characters their
own movies and TV shows.
I would love a buzzsaw for legs lady TV show.
Man.
Just 10 episodes of trying to turn that into
something viable.
Like a mini-series of her trying to walk around.
Oh yeah.
I think it's got legs.
I would imagine having buzz saws for legs
is not...
Ooh.
Thank you.
And no, I just think that that's hilarious.
It's this weirdly...
There's so much that you could do with this
universe.
It's so goofy and stupid.
And I would love to see somebody approach
it just full throttle.
What if...
Talk to me.
Here's my final pitch before we go.
What if somehow Defenders of Dynatron City
and Bionic Six were combined.
Because they kind of have a similar vibe,
right?
They're both got that retro-futurism thing.
They both have weird science going on.
They both have the ability for tongue-in-cheek
wackiness to happen.
And they're basically all superhero stories
dealing with ridiculous villains.
And they've both fallen into the public domain I'm betting.
Probably.
Let's hope so.
I have one final pitch.
Okay.
Talk to me.
The B plot of that series is that there are
monsters living in the sewers, learning how
to scare children.
Perfect.
I love it.
I want it.
Let's do it.
We could call it...
So the cinematic universe...
Yeah.
We could call it, Aaahh!!!
Defenders of Bionic City.
Perfect.
That's slick as snot.
Rolls right off the tongue.
They all have to get together.
Yeah.
At the end, the monsters come out of the sewers
and they're like, "We're here to help you."
They save the day.
Yeah.
They scared the villain away.
Perfect.
And one of them is Frankenbeans.
Thanks for watching.
Please hit like and subscribe so you don't
miss a single episode.